a dance off at stake the title of
Russia's best break dancer and
potentially the chance to compete for
the first ever Olympic breakdancing
medals in next year's Paris games
as Russia launched its full-scale
invasion of Ukraine last year many
International sporting organizations
banned Russian and Bella Russian
athletes from competitions but with time
more exceptions are being made last year
for me it was like a like a kick because
for two three months
I was really like in depression but
Olympics was like goal number one
and its go take a lot of time take
program for my mind
and keep focused on this goal on stage
Sergey goes by Bumblebee
he won the individual b-boy gold medal
at the 2018 summer youth Olympics where
break dancing made its debut
and with the senior games now a
realistic goal the 22 year old is
practicing four hours every day
breakdancing is popular in Russia and
many athletes your hope will be able to
continue chasing their dream of bringing
home a gold medal in this sport in next
year's summer Olympic Games in Paris
watching on one of the most prominent
sport coaches in this country a woman
who's in charge of preparing Russia's
rhythmic gymnasts she says her team too
is ready to compete
Russian team has
51 Olympic medals and 400
52.
medal of world championship and European
Champions
it's a good result
25 years we are first in Olympic Games
Sport and politics is very different
nonetheless The ioc Remains under
pressure from more than 30 countries
that are calling for a ban on all
Russian athletes at the games arguing a
country that launched the war has no
place in any International sporting
competition
still a chance if a receding one then of
disappointment for these young fans Keen
to see their Heroes on the biggest stage
bumblebee says for him break dancing is
freedom something that shouldn't be
constrained by politics dorsa Jabari Al
Jazeera Moscow